this week on quadriga
the rise of populism a threat to Europe
the far-right National Front emerged
from a first round of regional elections
as the strongest political force in
France many are now asking if party
leader marine lepen could be the
country's next president and France
isn't the only country in Europe where
right-wing parties are gaining ground at
the top of the populist agenda fear of
migrants and fear of Islamist terror the
simple answer to complex challenges is
more nationalism and less EU that
message clearly resonates with many
voters how great a threat to Europe do
populist parties pose coming to you from
Berlin quadriga
the international debate your host this
week peter craven solo in a very warm
welcome indeed to this latest edition of
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
the German capital and the question
we're asking today is this is the rise
of populism of right-wing populism with
France very much to the fore a threat to
Europe and to try and answer that
question I'm joined here in the studio
by three seasoned observers and analysts
let me introduce them to you without any
further ado beginning with Ulrich again
rule she is a political analyst and
founder and director of the European
democracy lab now Ulrika says the fron
nacional is not a new phenomenon in
france and the recent terror attacks are
not the real reason for its surging
popularity
indeed she says the front Nacional is a
People's Party that brings together the
lost citizens of the Republic we're also
joined by Judy Dempsey who is a writer
and analyst for the Carnegie Foundation
who in a long and distinguished career
in journalism has also worked for a host
of international media outlets and she
says marine lepen could well become the
next president of France Europe's future
would then rest with her and Eureka
Herman is an author and a journalist
with the berlin-based daily the target
site of all the taps as it's also known
she focuses on business and finance and
believes that
Germany's economic policies a poly to
blame for the growing support for the
frog Nacional in France welcome to I'd
like to begin with you Judy and I'd like
to begin with a quote from a very
interesting and courageous woman I'm
sure she is familiar to you Beata class
felt born here in Germany born here in
Berlin she's in her 70s now she's lived
a lot of her life in France and she's
made a reputation for herself for
hunting down former Nazi war criminals
what she has to say is important and
what she has said about recent
developments in France is this what we
are seeing in France she says reminds me
of the year 1933 in Germany
it's strong stuff is she right she's not
right but she could be right and
substituting Jews for Muslims Muslims
for Jews it's becoming very very
worrying we've seen this what's
happening to the United States must be
quite shocking to be a Muslim and now
Muslims are being targeted in France and
the Frog Nacional is directed against
and Islam against a religion it's it's
very worrying at one hopes that European
leaders will not allow this slide into
this self-destruction we go what do you
say friends today like Germany in 1933
is that a valid comparison in any way
well comparisons are always difficult
yes well let's state here but I agree
with mrs. Dempsey that the problem is
that we are losing the life CT of a la
république of the French Republic yes
we're in first what it's basically that
the state is a neutral towards religion
this is what the French founded in
nineteen five and that is the lycée
tastes or the neutrality - what's
religion is a basic condition for the
French Republic in the sense of modern
republicanism and this is indeed
something which the four national is
deconstructing I give one precise
example marine lepen is probably not the
real danger but Mahayana lepen her and
nice 25 years old as she had said in the
before the regional irregular elections
now in a in a speech in Ning
she said that who is not sort of
dedicated to the kings of France and
does not belong to to France and this
has a little spin and the very
interesting spin here is Sheba she
refers to Mack bloke who's a French
historian by the way historian killed by
the nazis in 1944 but what she does was
this quote that she misuses is who
doesn't feel for the French kings is not
French and that is UK you could say that
this is a slippery route because this is
sort of a priest step to program yeah
because you say who belongs to a people
and who not and this has clearly an
empty Islam anti-muslim spin and is
basically the deconstruction of the
French notion of Republic which
integrates citizens and so I would agree
it's very dangerous
it's certainly a winning formula because
she's gaining in popularity gaining more
and more votes the strongest force in
French politics now you said that you
talked in the quote that I gave at the
top of the show you said there are there
are lost citizens in France that are the
people who are voting for the front us
you know who are these lost citizens I
think the four nationalists nourished by
many sort of lost citizens and the lost
citizens are we thought in the past that
the four national is strong in the bond
used where the French Communist Party
was strong in the past and there is a
clear shift from communist rule to four
national vote in the 80s already so
that's the first sort of lost people
which is the poly Terra of modern
industries ation and deconstruction yeah
the second obviously the farmers which
are also here France is a very rural
country and then the agricultural policy
of the European Union is also a very big
problem so that's the second group the
third group is young unemployed people
yes the force and so she is collecting
all these people who feel lost in a sort
of modernization process and what we
need to look at in sociological terms is
there's a very strong rural urban divide
in France something which we are not
knowing in Germany that much which is a
much more homogeneous country and it's
the rural urban divide which two logics
is driving the force of the phone Astra
now because the rural areas didn't
survive in a way the very deep austerity
policy which we have been doing in the
European Union okay I've got a picture
now of where the front Nacional is
coming from briefly how dangerous is the
front us you know it is dangerous I mean
we are talking about 30% but that's
average if you look and more detail sort
of breakdown data what we see is the
marine lepen has many regions where she
rank where she turns out 40 and plus she
has a couple of constituencies where
she's above 50 and the the only thing
which protects us from seeing this is
that the French have a first passed the
first electron security voting system
and not proportional system had the
french-german proportional voting system
we would clearly see that the four
Nacional is somewhere between SPD and
CDU which is largely Forks pitaya which
is a People's Party in that sense and we
are not seeing this or in the other one
we are just protected to see this by the
election law in France
Arica Hammond is it can you give us any
sense of the extent to which the front
Nacional is typical for far-right
populist parties around Europe and there
are many to choose from or atypical well
it is very typical in the sense that it
is against the EU it is a very national
party it is typically in the
scientifical in the sense that it's an
in-group out-group scheme so the they
are the French and then there are the
foreigners or the Muslims whoever who
are not supposed to belong to the
national group and then it is very
typical in the sense that it has a
strong social component in the sense
that they want to raise the pensions
they want to raise their benefits for
the unemployed they want to spend more
money on Social Security but only for
French of course not for the Muslims so
and it is very typical also in the sense
that they do not have a coherent program
it's just mostly it's just against being
everything the establishment in Paris
somehow stipulates and
I think a very specific idea they have
which really should the Germans
alarm is that marine lepen says well we
are against Germany because Germany
tries to erect a German Europe and I
think that's new because for example the
Dutch populace I'm not against Germany
or the Austrian populist also very
strong are not against Germany that's
the first that's the first public
populist party in Europe that actively
says Germany is the problem I mean first
of all it's only the beginning for
marking the pen and the beginning is not
always lead to success but the
psychological impact so far it gives the
populist parties in across Europe such a
boost
you see fans can do it and despite all
the elites against her and with the
whole issue of the British referendum
whether to stay in or outside of you
that's going to boost the the anti
Europe party the polls the new Polish
government the nationalist Conservative
government which is very populist
they're riding high on this we're being
very under litical here being very
rational in the approach to it and I'm
very grateful for that because that is
very much the backdrop but this is this
is a cause for extreme concern
especially around the future of Europe
surely this is its if it's not stopped
we will lose Europe and the fact that
Enrico brought in the this attacking
Germany from France it's the
franco-german axis that thought
stability brought the European Union
brought this kind of special integration
of Europe and if that goes then the
bedrock of of this European architecture
is gone this is very very serious
yeah but sort of the franco-german
engine always functioned on the sort of
similarity or the sort of symmetry of
both countries and this symmetry is
broken since ever Germany got unified
because not only we gained enormous lean
economic power this is the argument that
basically the way of the German
dominance in how to run the eurozone or
the the
euro governance was seen in in in France
and that is what mrs. Hammond just said
that the French are reacting in the
negative and say we do not want to be
governed by a German sort of euro
governance feature here and that fuels
mahine lepen so we were losing the
franco-german symmetry on that economic
level but we are losing it also on the
political level since ever then Mackel
is basically the leader of Europe you go
to China to the US - she speaks to
poutine so but we've also Germany gained
political power and the asymmetry of the
frame could join in tandem which were
the carrier of the old European Union is
no longer there so there's a clear
rupture in in sort of in that engine
function okay one thing we can agree on
when we talk about the far-right
nationalist parties is that they tend to
pander and play - the kind of fears that
many many people across Europe have in
the globalized in world judy's agreeing
with we will talk about it in just a
second that's just before we do that
let's just have a look at what those
fears precisely are many Europeans feel
traditional parties have been ignoring
their troubles worries and concerns
populist slike those in the National
Front profit from that focusing on fear
such as the fundamental fear of allowing
in too many migrants in 2015 around a
million refugees have fled to Germany
alone then there's the fear of ghettos
like those surrounding Frances cities
and fear of the Islamist terror they
might spawn
and not to forget the fear of Eurocrats
in Brussels making all the decisions
populist parties say they care more
about the big multinationals than
citizen rights and last but not least
there's the fear of unemployment and
poverty
that's why right-wing populist parties
have also gained footholds in Europe's
wealthier nations Judy Dempsey are those
fears real or justified unemployment is
not a pleasant situation to be in
and there's armies of young people
without a perspective and Germany's is
probably one of the fortunate countries
one or two other that don't have a high
unemployment rate among the youth but if
the youth are waiting to be channeled or
to be captured by populist parties or
indeed by Isis by the so-called Islamic
state and this is highly highly
dangerous and leaders the the EU leaders
have a called summit on this but
actually it has to be much more radical
the approach to deal with unemployment
if you if you can't deal with the
unemployment you're not going to
actually dampen the the flames of this
populist movement imaginary or justified
because I do think it's a very important
question one of your clips said that the
the populist are more against the big
companies and care for citizens right
and let me pick on this we have seen
this um collects affair in the European
Parliament was this tax evasion stuff
and there you know the Commission takes
P treatment in Luxembourg and Hunca was
affected the it was the right-wing
populist parties who brought in the
proposal to do winter zooming saucers an
investigation thing yeah and none of the
other parties basically voted for that
so what do we see is that something
which is right and normal to do which we
should have done cannot be voted because
the other parties are not signing which
the populist party so we do have
basically hollowed out policy mechanisms
because we say these are populist
parties we cannot vote with them but we
don't do the right thing with
which is to have that committee on your
collects so there are dysfunctional is
in the systems because we exclude them
but it helps us not to get it it
prevents us from doing the right thing
okay
a structural problem there but I think
there's more to it well yeah I think
that what you have just have to see that
the unemployment rate in France is
really very high compared to Germany
especially and that is not just
something that effects a France or is
due to French policies but it's a
Germany exporting its unemployment to
France and the trick was that the
Germans just pushed down the real wages
in order to be more competitive and now
France lost 20% of its competitiveness
on the world markets and also in the
euro area so now the Germans saw their
goods and we have enormous export
surpluses in the French they lose out
the front Nacional existed a long time
before Germany started dictating if
that's the word budgetary probity to the
fringe no no the German trick to push
down the wages is 15 years old and in
fact you can really see in the French
figures that they started to get into
trouble in 2004 so and at the same time
that the Germans pushed their goods on
the French market and on the world
market you can see that their front
firmness you know it rises
according to unemployment in France it's
not only about people who are already
unemployed it's also about those people
fearing to be perhaps unemployed you
know it's just if you start to somehow
erode its the stability of a society
people start to react understand that
fear but people are also people also
have concerns they say they vote for the
front Nacional and other similar parties
around Europe because so they're because
they're their challenge let's put it
like that by changing patterns within
their society Kennedy was the enemy can
we say something we are talking about
fears but my point would be that and and
then is why I put that a committee into
place because much of the things that
the populace are claiming for or
requesting and we know things it's not
about fears they are right they're not
taken seriously by the urban elite and
no the problem is and this is what mrs.
Hammond said the the the system that use
is not reacting to legitimate reproaches
which are brought up by the populace
Vivi we always say they are just they
are having fears no there is a reality
behind and we should take that we a
little bit for serious because the
system is dysfunctional the system is
producing social unrest and so on so
forth and as long as the system just
says no no that they they are all driven
by fears we have a we have a problem
here because in many points this the the
so-called populist have a fair and right
and legitimate point to point to okay
first of all arica this this idea of the
the legitimacy in some ways of the EU
institutions it's been going on for a
long long time and very little action
has been taken
yeah so there's a complete the gap
between the society and the people is
much wider than ever before this is the
first thing secondly this this crisis I
agree with you Rika you have to engage
you have to you can't you can't push
these populist parties and off into
rivers they are there and they are
reality and you don't eat the policies
you have a dialogue but I feel there's
something much more fundamental taking
place across Europe
it's the decay of the post 1945
political system the to the the the big
parties the the the status quo parties
they've run their course in many ways
the big block parties do they're sort of
atrophied they haven't embraced the
younger generation they've survived a
50s 60s and 70s but now we have we have
a demand by younger generation but the
demands of globalization that need a
kind of new political structures and new
political parties to actually be
inclusive it is sometimes said that the
answer to the conundrum that you're
talking about here is that the political
parties the traditional parties that
they adopt some of the policies of the
populist parties and try and beat them
at their own game indeed it's not the
way to go no no I think what what is
happening is that you know we are having
all these peoples requests yeah in the
sense of force so volunteer the to stir
the the the the the wishes of the people
against what the system is providing so
this is also volunteer general so I
think in analysis in
analytical terms is we have a system in
the EU which is so dysfunctional that it
didn't provide public goods or volunteer
general for enough people we are losing
out more and more people in the lower
quintals and and 25-30 percent of
basically systemic losers in terms of
unemployment of the farmers or or or and
these people are now turning against the
system
Martin Schultz the president of the
European Parliament came out this week
and said that Europe the European Union
is in danger from all these developments
why doesn't the EU respond by finally
getting putting it you know getting its
house in order
well it can't it can't it can't for a
very complex reason that's not easy to
solve the crisis of Europe is a crisis
of self-confidence who don't want to
solve it we don't we don't feel
confident enough to actually to actually
engage and actually describe proper
Stanford and how are we going to defend
our society I agree on this but we have
all the policy tools in the cells which
are we do a fiscal union we do a sane
taxation with we prevent that text
evasion stuff we do social policies I
mean all these sort of blueprints for
what should have been done to get a
decent euro governance out there since
ever Jack the law in 89 said that a
monetary union comes along with social
Union we are fighting that game for 20
years
we never unfolded a true euro governance
which would basically correspond to a
decent policy mix where you have
obviously a fiscal Union it together
with a monetary union we just didn't do
these things and the system is now
running out empty because we have these
proposals in the shelves for years and
years and we have all the
dysfunctionality that we could never put
them into place and now we are paying
the bill for this we have the European
problem that you've just been talking
about the problem that the EU level the
Brussels problem we have the economic
problem that you've been talking about
we have to trade the threat of of
terrorism which is a very acute threat
at this point in time where is all this
going to lead what's the worst-case
scenario well I think the worst-case
scenario would be that many countries in
Europe adopt the Hungarian policy I mean
if you look at what happened
and with what is now being implemented
in Poland then what you see is the
country that is in a way still a
democracy because every four years there
are elections being held and you can
also say okay these elections are more
or less fair but in between these
elections the whole country is being
changed the media are controlled the the
courts somehow streamlined they are no
longer really independent you can see
that foreigners are being excluded and
in a strong national movement and in a
way it's no longer a true democracy and
it is no longer able to somehow
cooperate with other state governments
or States so you'll have a even if there
is the European Union called European
Union you will have lots of
nationalistic states but somehow try to
to increase their own benefits in Poland
same nationalism here but there are two
things they could have more nationalism
less freedom
what is interesting you mentioned
marking the dependi saying and you have
to support the French kings well you
mentioned Hungary Eureka and the famous
slogan in 1956 by jános kádár
he who is not against us is with us or
he was not with us is against us and yes
you have this extraordinary system our
development in Poland and Hungary and in
the Baltic States but particularly
Poland and Hungary and how many of these
young people have found work and a way
of life in really strong democracies
like Ireland and Britain Spain Portugal
and yet their leaders want to act as if
it turned their own countries into a
liberal democracies and not take the
benefits of Europe so they want to coast
Europe even though it's a your open
Europe that has given this younger
generation of perspective but I mean
that you can see that I agree this is
somehow strange but you can see that
very well with Poland Poland does not
want to want to take any refugee but you
have 700,000 Polish working in Germany
and 700,000 working in Britain so but
the Polish find it completely normal
that they are allowed to go anywhere at
the same time not taking in anybody and
so that
and you have the same with Hungary but
somehow strangely people do not realize
that that is somehow strange the same
with Switzerland there are lots of Swiss
living in Germany but they themselves
want to don't want to take anyone I
think that is the problem that there I
mean first we just that
complex systems cannot solve crisis as
when the crisis is there yeah and this
is what we experienced since the EU in
all respects is a very complex system
but for complex system to fix it sort of
quickly when the crisis there's most of
the time too late and that's what we are
experiencing is the helplessness that we
have a complex sort of system here your
governance refugees and so on so forth
and the only reflects that that system
can have is that we cluster it in
national containers and now the National
answers is the good one that the
reflects but B we are not we are no
longer having the capacity to overcome
the functional this for the the
dysfunctionality and the flaws of the
European system we have one minute to go
refugee policy on the shelves which you
mentioned my great fear is that the
polish the Polish reluctance to take
refugees the Czechs are so vast it's
directed against Germany yeah I agree
and that's the great worrying thing that
Germany's becoming the the the
scapegoats and the bogeyman throughout
Europe will marine lepen become the next
French president hopefully not but cheek
would could we see a return a repeat of
the flawless in our here in Germany if
it crisis hits yes
what's your worst-case scenario in one
sentence
the pen becoming in Tbilisi okay we're
gonna have to leave it there I hope
we've given you plenty of food for
thoughts thanks very much for joining us
bye-bye from now from Berlin just